ta mère avait plusieurs fois que que les
gens me disent tu as des traits
autistiques en fait soit on dit ça et un
jour j'ai j'ai commencé à faire des
recherches j'ai sur internet et j'ai
appris qu'en fait le syndrome d'Asperger
s'exprime de façon différente chez les
hommes chez les femmes ça se voit
beaucoup plus chez les hommes
parce que les femmes vont vraiment
essayer de compenser en fait pour pour
cacher leur trait et pour se fondre
vraiment dans la masse en fait et quand
j'ai commencé à lire les
caractéristiques des femmes asperger
c'est sûr c'est ça je me suis vraiment
reconnue et ça faisait aucun doute pour
moi
j'ai quand même fait les tests chez une
psychiatre etc pour avoir vraiment les
tests officiels pour avoir le diagnostic
officiel tous les liens sont faits dans
ma tête j'ai j'ai eu en gros j'ai eu les
clés de ma vie quoi j'ai compris juste
comment je fonctionnais
j'aime bien avoir des moments où je me
retrouve seule juste pour pour vivre mon
monde intérieur en fait pour réfléchir à
tout ce que tout ce dont j'ai envie de
réfléchir c'est pas tant que j'aime pas
j'ai besoin des relations sociales et
j'adore être avec des gens mais j'ai
besoin j'ai vraiment besoin à côté de
mon moment pour pour me recharger quoi
on a beaucoup de problèmes à comprendre
les conventions sociales du coup mon
cerveau il fonctionne à 1000 à l'heure
en permanence pour comprendre ce qui
m'entoure comprendre ce qu'on attend de
moi ce que je dois faire comment réagir
etc donc pour moi ça génère vraiment
énormément de fatigue tu la vois dans
d'autres moments c'est quand elle est
c'est quand elle souffre quand elle fait
des crises d'angoisse tu sais pas
l'aider tu peux être là mais parfois
être là c'est déjà trop parce qu'en fait
elle veut pas que tu sois là elle va
être seul c'est difficile même de
l'extérieur parce que quand il y a
quelqu'un que tu aimes qui en détresse
et que tu et que tu sais pas comment
l'aider c'est très difficile
il y a des moments qui pourraient
travailler moi et de sortir et tu te dis
je vais dire genre
parce que c'est plus facile de dire ça
que de dire je suis autiste et j'ai pas
envie
forcément puis les gens en a ils le
croient pas ou ils comprennent pas donc
ça sert à rien ça n'est pas seulement un
trait de caractère c'est c'est elle est
autiste asperger c'est juste un schéma
psychique
hors norme pour moi c'est vraiment
quelque chose de positif parce que je
sais que j'ai une façon de penser qui
m'est propre je sais que j'ai mes
propres codes en fait j'ai mes propres
règles et je pense que ça participe
aussi à mon humour le fait d'avoir aucun
filtre c'est sûr que forcément ça m'a
amené aussi à faire cette humour là
c'est pas une maladie c'est un don et
c'est ce qui la rend aussi tellement
attachante tu vois elle est très forte
très sûre et très fragile et tellement
différente
tellement à part c'est ce qui lui permet
aussi d'écrire ces textes c'est ce qui
lui permet aussi d'avoir ce successeur
scène c'est bien la mer en fait pour toi
il y a pas trop de monde un petit peu
trop de monde sur le bateau
genre moi par exemple
sur un bateau tu vas pas de moi
je t'aime Laura
moi je t'aime c'est gentil
bah normalement tu me dis moi aussi j'ai
dit merci c'est pas suffisant